what's up everybody what's going on guys
this is Rob and and and we've broken
50,000 subscribers were actually a fifty
thousand and four subscribers and and
I'm so excited
it's so exciting you know my channels
growing so fast and and the reason why
I'm making this video is because I
wanted to inform you guys that I'm
starting a cup filled out I'm starting a
video blog channel I'm starting a
channel where I'm just going to talk to
you guys through video blogs instead of
uploading video blogs on the Marvel
explain because that channels from
Marvel Comics and I'd like to keep it
from Marvel Comics but instead of just
uploading it on video blogs there I'm
gonna start a whole new channel forward
and it's just gonna be me talking to you
guys about things that I happen to be
thinking about about things I just feel
like talking about on camera and seeing
as this is the first official video blog
for that for that channel for for Rob's
for the Rob talks which is actually what
I'm calling and the link will be in the
description for it because this is the
first official video blog I wanted to
talk to you guys about like working for
things that you guys love working for
the things that you want to do because
you know I think that this whole YouTube
thing has taught me some really
important lessons and one of the most
important lessons that I've learned is
that if you love it enough it's not a
job and if you love it enough you'll do
whatever you need to to succeed at it
you know the fact that I work a
full-time job and I've worked double
shifts you know it can make life really
difficult on YouTube there's been times
when I have gotten off work you know
7:00 a.m. after working 16 hours come
home work on YouTube videos and gone
right back to work you know at 3 o'clock
with an hour and a half two hours of
sleep because succeeding on YouTube
means that much to me like it's that
important to me and I know a lot of you
guys out there know exactly where I'm
coming from with this whole thing I know
a lot of you guys out there know what
I'm talking about you guys are college
kids you guys are studying for 20 hours
in the library somewhere getting ready
for your final exams you guys are
medical students you know getting ready
to take the boards and you guys are
studying your butts off you know you're
going into law school you're taking the
LSAT you know so a lot of you guys are
know exactly what I'm talking about and
so you can relate when I say that if you
love something you work your ass off you
do whatever you have to do to make it
succeed and and that's that's not advice
that I would give you guys you know
a lot of people out there will tell you
guys that like you can't succeed at
something or they'll tell you guys let's
like this camera's not senator right
there we go but a lot of you guys a lot
of people will say that you guys can't
do something they'll say you know this
is impossible for you to do and and in
truth or full of um you know maybe
it's because their life sucks they feel
like they can't do it maybe it's because
you know they've relegated themselves to
mediocrity I don't know but don't worry
about those guys you know if you love it
do it if you want to be a youtuber then
by god go be a youtuber grab a iPhone 5
or an iPhone 4 or something like that
and just do video blogs don't worry
about being the biggest youtuber on the
planet just do what you love if what you
want to be is a youtuber being a
youtuber if you want to be an architect
go to college take some calculus courses
and become an architect you know do what
it is that you love in life because in
truth life's just too short to live by
somebody else's standards and if you
feel you're not satisfied with where you
are and change it because there's no
reset button here there's no redo
there's no you get to the end of your
life and you say ok now that I know
everything I know now let's let's do
things different like that's the end of
the road there's nothing left and so you
know just make sure that that the life
that you live is the life that you want
to live you know like I've said before
with this whole YouTube thing the time
is gonna come when I'm gonna move out to
move out west when moving out to Seattle
you know I'm actually having lunch with
Jessica this Thursday and that's what
I'm gonna talk to her about is to
basically say look you know like I love
you I absolutely love you for like 4
years I've loved her but she's a part of
a life that I need to leave behind and
when I move out west I'm leaving
everything behind
I'm leaving friends I'm leaving family
I'll still come back here to come back
and see family on holidays of course but
you know I will not really be traveling
back here that much everything's gonna
get left behind this this whole thing is
a new life for me you know a new a new
world that I'm stepping into and I'm
embracing it I'm running into it with no
regrets and you know you guys should do
the same thing you know if whatever it
is that you want to do in life whatever
it is that you feel like would make you
happy then do it I mean there's no
reason not to
you know I'm you're smart enough I don't
even know you and I can tell you you're
smart enough to do anything you want to
do and a lot of people say a lot of
people say stuff like you know well you
know
and you can do anything you want to if
you put your mind to it and sometimes I
don't mean it sometimes they do mean it
but I'm here to tell you guys you can do
anything you want to you can you know if
whatever it is you guys want to do in
life go do it you know not only to be
you know all existential here all Tony
Robbins like you know but I just think
it's important you guys know that that
you guys know that if you've ever
doubted yourself if you're ever unsure
about what it is you're capable of then
I'm here to tell you you can do anything
you want with your life it's just a
matter of whether or not you have the
drive and the desire to do it so anyway
um first official video blog comes to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it about
five minutes or so so yeah 50,000
subscribers I'm so excited and I will
catch you guys later peace